in this video we'll talk about
topoisomerase these enzymes catalyze the
changes in dna topology by transient
breaks in the dna
now dna undergoes a lot of problems one
of them is a super coiling problem let's
try to understand that by using this
thread analogy
so these two threads are entangled with
each other and let's say you are trying
to relieve this kind of strain
by separating each of these strands you
can do it
from the end and after a certain point
of time you would see that strands is
getting more entangled and getting more
torsional stress
so this is how we can understand a super
coiling problem and this problem is
faced by the dna all the time inside the
nucleus of the cell where it has to be
packed into a defined volume
imagine
the situation for a e coli cell
in one experiment the cell of e coli was
burst open and the huge amount of dna
was pulled all around
imagine how e coli can really package
this much amount of dna into a small
volume and this is all possible due to
this super coiling
effect so the
overall topology of the dna has to be
taken care of but who takes care of this
problem
but before that try to understand that
this problem is really important
especially in context of several
molecular biology processes
like replication or transcription if the
topological problem is not taken care of
these biological processes would not
take place so obviously for the survival
of the
cell these processes need to go on and
that is why topological problems has to
be taken care of
one of the enzymes that take cares of
this problem is topoisomerase which is a
class of enzyme that can relax and alter
the topology of the dna
and it can introduce single or double
strand breaks which are transient in
nature and then it can allow the dna to
be unentangled or unwound and at the end
of this process the dna backbone is
actually released
now let's talk about the classification
of topoisomerase
there are two categories of
topoisomerase type one topoisomerase
which cuts only single strand of the dna
and type 2 topoisomerase that leaves
both the strands
let us try to understand the mechanism
by looking at only one type of
topoisomerase
now before that
let me tell you that after the activity
of topoisomerase the dna would lose its
super coils and it would be more relaxed
just like in this particular image you
can see all the other
uh
all the other loops of the chromosome
are super coiled but in this particular
loop the dna has lost its super coil and
now more relaxed
so this is type one two poi isomerase
which can
give rise to a cut in one only one
strand only but there are type two
topoisomerase which can cut both the
strands and after cutting the strand it
would proceed by a swivel and strand
passage mechanism in a moment it will be
really clear
the range of reactions that is performed
by super performed by these enzymes
involves dna super coil
unknotting of the single stranded
circles and decatination
so the type 1 topoisomerase will use a
tyrosine moiety as a source of
nucleophile this nucleophile will attack
the dna backbone and thereby creating a
transient enzyme dna adduct
and the three prime hydroxyl group would
be freed up
then one strand in this particular case
look at the dark strand this strand
would be swiveled and passed through the
other broken strand
like this you can see the initial
position of the strand is marked by the
dotted line
and the final position is marked by the
solid lines
and this
light colored strand is now
sealed by a topoisomerase enzyme and
this is how the topoisomerase takes care
of the supercoiling problem and it
relieves the extra torsion
now we understood how topoisomerase type
one works let us summarize the
differences between topoisomerase type
one and two we already noticed that
topoisomerase type one has cuts only one
strand of the dna whereas two isomerized
type two cuts both the strand when it
comes to atp hydrolyzing topoisomerase
type one doesn't need atp whereas to
voice memorize type 2 requires atp
now we already looked at the
dna breakage in one versus doubles
one strand versus the both the strands
then let's talk about the structure
so topoisomerase type one is monomer
whereas type two is heterodimer when it
comes to changing the linking number
which is a parameter to understand a dna
topology
topoisomer is one change the linking
number strictly to one or in multiples
of one to poisson is type two change the
linking number
to two units plus minus two units
so that pretty much summarize the
differences between these two enzymes
and their function
okay you can get all the flash cards and
notes in my facebook channel you can get
uh many dynamic flash cards in my
facebook page so link is provided in the
description don't forget to check it out
as usual don't forget to like share and
subscribe you can support me on patreon
my courses are present in our academy
using our code mp10 you can